okay we're back there just pawns on to
[ __ ] with that
Thank You gratitude Anita say eh eh eh
sooner laughs I cannot hide wet dead
the fact is that it's been [ __ ]
disgraceful fielding is in London
America this used to be downtown London
used to be fighting in the streets oh
really furious unrelenting resistance
then analysis born in the London monitor
and everything with this shift from
there they just do whatsoever they
please now I gather playing level
everything he made this [ __ ]
monstrosity it's not Nazi research for
selling business aviation space all
kinds of evil [ __ ] transpiring Caroline
and the other pilots should be over the
radio tower by now you see it at that
Anya's operating the radio back in
Berlin you can reach and using this oh
my god I'll have this is where you go
off again again so long blaskowitz you
make this count
that's right Betty
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
what's up [ __ ]
a shockwave from over here it's all up
to you now press coverage position radio
tower approximately seven blocks from
the location you have to find a way to
the top floor of the Nautica and orphan
sitting the doors sensei me and
co-pilots can get inside that guy was
not [ __ ] her out okay
I came from this way I guess you got to
go this way is that says something here
oh where is there a gap [ __ ] it's not
even charge a higher charge or four yes
[ __ ] thank you
okay holy [ __ ] what's going on what am I
supposed to do okay good I got no
[ __ ] Ehrmann out excuse it all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] what is that a hat
right did I just go this way just go up
had to go this way maybe I could go out
that's one exit Oh
they said [ __ ] [ __ ] and that
[ __ ] stupid again [ __ ] up every day
now oh yeah I can't even pay attention
to hear those you're so [ __ ] hot I'm
sorry but like anywhere like a [ __ ]
mask or something
hey turns around my dick is wet
you think I hear a doggie what is that
noise
Layton wasn't leaps and hosen fancy
husband got suckered x-rays less
Corphish
and Bobby's desk is not being trade
what's going on like a pocket
hang-gliding
that's not collinear that more
okay does that soon your legs shut what
the [ __ ] is that sir but I made no
trouble I have no paper with you the
[ __ ] is that
okay okay
[Applause]
athlete does that
probably shut a lot of cars over there
ah
well [ __ ] and if you like that
Wow watched a cup that's always it the
on so update maka okay
and that was my personal stake jet jet
and the Sun we are one in the Sun we
[Applause]
I have to run out of ammo here try not
to run out of ammo here
base anything that's hey Hach
I can hear it like moving around
what sigh mission a Thornton melon go
that was like
ah [ __ ]
okay I'm going to let a low on [ __ ]
right now
aunty aunty so is going eyes and buzz
senior this interesting [ __ ] over there
okay
oh [ __ ] I got a lot of [ __ ] up now
okay where's the moon room okay that's
what I'm really here for section you're
adorable the other one
oh shut [ __ ] it add another by so many
people
give me this [ __ ] give me this [ __ ] you
look [ __ ] ah ah ah stop [ __ ] me this
what happens we go pair tactical [ __ ]
Nazi Germany take this bag great care
they get [ __ ] angry oh yeah
[Music]
I don't know what that does but I'm
going to call that
ah
okay enter the maintenance section door
top the moon dome from the air to reach
elevator shaft by the way to the top so
check behind me so [ __ ] [ __ ] read the
housings app stop [ __ ] me you
[ __ ] analog out
what did I get
why stop okay
I don't know baby I'm sure you get what
see what's going on over there but I'm
kind of busy
oh [ __ ] I was a good woman and what is
this [ __ ] I hate this [ __ ] app what
[Music]
happened to this guy Saten to the breaks
off an elevator
what could go there stand on the counter
wait what what's the counter way it
[Music]
here we go
man I'm handsome I'm always taking back
my hand so I am I think I found
something
oh do you see is such an artifact highly
technological in nature that's a mess
simple we're all [ __ ] like make it
understand
looks like Hebrew I think the Nazis are
trying to reverse engineer all this
stuff
are there any identifying marks sir just
so [ __ ] hot you should dog Abel '
Abel taro space yoke item Charlie how
uncle dog might be something in our
archives
Anya see if you can find any references
who got you shoot will do okay let's get
microphone II got I like to blast with
it
good catch earlier are you sure to bring
as much of this dots you should stop as
you can carry
will do
okay
that [ __ ] is half this [ __ ]
okay [ __ ] is that
fascinating
I get up there gotta be going in there
um was I going to say yeah there yeah
one more
okay so what am i doing in here stuff
[ __ ] is that
I see channel behind the north wall look
for what shooting this [ __ ] ok the
blueprint or is reinforced with yeah my
dad shut up waiting long
why's it so hazy in here into the okay
where's the counterweight then two
floors up oh okay one flora project
captain hey lady how do you know where I
am
anyone know
all righty
yeah are the boss
that's your motto
the [ __ ] is that
I should have never died Sunday
that thing robots
now
okay how'd I get all this thing
okay okay okay
yes yes yes
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
alright [ __ ] died [ __ ] I got now
hey some of this armor I got there there
gotta go left
what do you mean have to go left I got
to get up there somehow
fucking-a alright alright
okay where are they where are they
fucking-a they're all behind me
[Applause]
okay I got to figure out how to get up
there
okay here [ __ ] me up on this side
oh [ __ ]
okay
check
the [ __ ] is that
stop gap up I'll shove up [ __ ] perfect
come on come on [ __ ]
let's shoot one over here come on yes
[Music]
like an egg my clients like to my
question box
[Music]
okay
and this different type of God
what is this thing Karen
is it like blank you're becoming
yes stupid [ __ ] right now she's dead
not two robots dead broke all your [ __ ]
oh my god they're secure
yes I'm talking about it's a true
American hair right here okay so up Wow
I know I always get hurt yes there's a
ladder nice talking with that
they call me sergeant pestle
all right first things always blinking
[Music]
Kovich don't move you're getting
visitors okay it's Fergus fine in house
that [ __ ] crazy okay that girl is
getting old they'll talk did I just do
Oh [ __ ] what a circle all right come
on I'm coming
holy [ __ ] you just like [ __ ] leaving
wait for me
oh my god [ __ ] you got a [ __ ] piece
of metal on you Mike you okay they'll
get you down there I'm with Tonya shut
[Music]
I don't know
very bad
I'm pretty bad
how do we just like have this place so
we need to take
right what is the data usually which are
probably getting a long time I'm not
really look good you taking me
I don't look whatever to be you don't
look fine daughter uh yeah that's good
yeah okay I know but we got some episode
here on the aside thanks for watching
thank you